jaison's and georgia hi Jason welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show
hey David speak to you my friend you too
sir
how can I help no my wife and I had her
I've had it about two weeks ago so we're
just starting out come on on baby step
two love it
bringing home between seventy six
hundred and eight thousand a month but
we're about one hundred eighteen
thousand and that that includes
sixty-five thousand and student loans
between the two of us we got a brand-new
minivan and we have about forty thousand
on we leased vehicle this year
unfortunately for ten thousand five
hundred then we got about twenty five
hundred dollars and just interest-free
cars that were getting ready to pay off
my question was we don't really know
what to do with the cars considering you
bought brand-new so we're pretty upside
down and then the lease itself no idea
how we would get out of that there's
about ten thousand five hundred worth of
payments left but I don't know what a
buyout on it is or anything so you know
if you have that little if you have
little sidestep for a second if you have
that little amount left on payments
you're probably gonna lose almost that
much selling it you're probably that far
upside down versus the actual lease
payoff so you're probably riding that
one out that tells me why I got fourteen
months left all right well it's a three
year lease but nothing I paid $2.99 a
month on it and so well because what's
will last it says it's about ten five or
something like that if I paid every
single payment so I thought we just desk
snowball it but do when we're done snow
Boeing the ten thousand do we turn it
back in and or do we just dry down I
don't know you wouldn't you don't prepay
your lease payments I wouldn't do that
there's one of two options here you just
hold the car and pay the payments until
the end the lease and then turn the car
in that's option one okay and that's
gonna cost you ten thousand five hundred
dollars the way to analyze it then is
you can call them and ask what the early
buyout on the lease is how long have you
had the car we just got it in January
I'm gonna government employees
you're trading in a car and leased that
during the shutdown so that's how I
ended up with the lease so we've only
had it for January okay and so you're
six months into a 36 month so you got 30
months left mmm okay and what was the
sticker on the car in January
I don't you think I looked at that
roughly 30,000 to 1,000 what's it what
was it roughly I was assuming somewhere
around 30 20 25 30 all right let's just
call it 25 for example okay and you're
six months in so if that were the case
you'd probably have about 8,000 18,000
I'm sorry 19,000 left on the full buy
out of the lease if you want to pay the
car off and on it your pay off your
early pay off okay right you can call
him and ask for that number let's use
for example purposes let's say that that
was 20,000 bucks
okay you're early buy out and then you
call up and you or you look at Kelley
Blue Book and you say okay I can sell
this car right now for $14,000 okay I'm
just making these numbers up but if you
got to pay it off at 20 and you can sell
it for 14 that means you're 6,000 and
the whole so if you sell it now you're
gonna lose 6,000 if you keep it and
drive it for two and a half more years
you're gonna lose 10,000 I'd probably
keep it in that case right okay because
it's not enough savings but let's say
the numbers were reversed and or were
further apart and you know you could if
you sold it now it only it costs you
$8,000 but if you keep it it cost you
$18,000 what we're selling it now right
okay you see what I'm doing and so if
they're just looking at the cut those
two comparing those two things against
each other I think yours gonna it's
gonna cost you a little bit more to keep
it but not enough to screw was selling
it so I'm probably keeping it once you
run your numbers out now that's that
part the rest of it is this we just list
our debts smallest to largest what do we
do with the cars if you can be debt-free
not counting your house cars and
everything in two years
and if the total value of your vehicles
is less than half your annual income
then I would keep my cars that puts this
that puts the van on the bubble right
because your leased car is 25 and the
Vans 40 that's 65 and you don't make 130
right we make we make 150
oh my income is oh I missed something oh
no you gave me take-homes
okay yeah that's right okay all right
yeah okay so you're less than half your
annual income now if you're making 150
can we pay off a hundred which is
roughly your debt in two years yes you
can correct and so if you can be
debt-free you and the cars are less than
half your annual income you can keep the
cars the only and and so the cars aren't
so big that they are dragging you down
in other words and they're not so big
that they're all depreciating their
butts off because you got sixty five
thousand dollars with the vehicles
they're gonna be worth thirty thousand
total in twenty minutes
these things are gonna go down in value
like crazy and you know it you know when
you lose that much money it's harder to
build wealth that's what it comes down
to so if your cars were a little bit
more expensive they'd be right there I
mean you're I'm probably gonna go ahead
and work my way through this if I'm you
and keep them both and you you know keep
the leased car and then you got up with
some money safe to buy a car at the end
the lease right sounds perfect man I
appreciate it
cash cash no no borrowing